at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking when I also your personal
question I'm a cybernetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
this episode of the tim ferriss show is
brought to you by 99designs an
ex-officio 99designs
is the world's largest online
marketplace of graphic designers and I
have used 99 designs for years including
to get cover concepts for the 4-hour
body which went on to become number one
New York Times number one Wall Street
Journal it was a huge hit and here's how
it works and you can check everything
out including some of my competitions
you can see these book covers and so on
at 99designs com forward slash Tim
whether you need a logo a car app a web
design an app a thumbnail a t-shirt
whatever you go to 99 designs calm you
describe your project and then within a
week or less you have tons of designers
around the world who compete for your
business and submit different ideas and
designs and drafts you have an original
design that you love or you pay nothing
it is fantastic
I have used it I have mentioned it
before including in the 4-hour workweek
as a resource check it out
99designs comm forward slash Tim and if
you use that link you'll be able to see
what I've done on the platform you will
also get $99 as an upgrade for free
which will get you more designs more
submissions so check it out
ex-officio boy where do I begin I have a
long history with ex-officio ex-officio
makes clothing and as far back as 2007
2008 I had a hit video that went viral
called how to travel the world with 10
pounds or less and I talked about
ex-officio underwear ex-officio
underwear is lightweight ultra
lightweight quick drying and
antimicrobial why is this important well
I've gone through 20 plus countries with
two pairs of underwear before both from
ex-officio and I'm not alone in this
this might sound crazy but a lot of
executives for instance will take this
underwear they'll wash it in the sink or
somewhere else
roll it up in a towel like a burrito
step on it and a few hours later they
are completely dry completely clean you
don't have to just have to and yes they
have to be comfortable for all-day wear
but check out their clothing as well as
their underwear you can go to ex-officio
com forward slash Tim that's X DX o FF I
cio.com forward slash Tim and you can
see this video which has a bunch of
other packing tips but this underwear
this clothing is not just for the gents
ladies you have choices too and they
really have an incredible collection of
high quality products that I've used for
almost ten years now so check them out
ex-officio comm forward slash Tim hello
ladies and germs this is Tim Ferriss yet
again running out the door to a flight
but I have such an exciting episode I
can barely contain myself
I might just wee myself on my way across
the country but I digress
probably TMI let me answer just a couple
questions what is this podcast about you
long-term listeners might know long term
long time that it's about dissecting
excellence trying to tease apart what
makes world-class performers so good at
what they do
finding the tools and tactics that you
can apply in this episode features Maria
Popova I'm about to explain who she is
and if you don't know who she is or if
you are intimately familiar with who she
is you're in for a treat first I'll
answer a question that a lot of people
ask me in that is what are you reading
well what I'm reading right now is two
books comprised of two books the first
is William Goldman adventures in the
screen trade Goldman is the screenwriter
behind such movies as The Princess Bride
one of my favorites of all time and
Butch Cassidy is the Sundance Kid the
second book is John Muir wilderness
essays so very different both very very
good and highly recommended the
adventures in the screen trade is a
little outdated with some of the
contents because it's related to film
and it was written in the 80s but there
are a lot of timeless principles and
Goldman is just hilarious
but moving on the guest maria Popova oh
my goodness where to start she would
describe herself as a reader writer
interestingness hunter gatherer and
curious mind at
large what does that mean it'll all make
sense in just a few seconds while she's
written for all sorts of amazing outlets
like the Atlantic in the New York Times
I find her most amazing project to be
brain pickings dot-org and I'm not alone
in this founded in 2006 as a weekly
email that she sent out to seven friends
co-workers really very informal brain
pickings was eventually brought online
and now it gets more than five million
readers per month
it is massive many of you ask what blogs
do you read often what do you do online
where do you spend most of your time the
answer is that I read very few sites
consistently I don't have that type of
loyalty but brain pickings is one of the
few it is a treasure trove it is Maria's
one-woman labor of love her subjective
lens on what matters it's also an
inquiry into how to live and what it
means to lead a good life this is what
hooks me of course because she'll pull
from excerpts and reading from the
Stoics my favorite Seneca - Mark Twain
Oscar Wilde and everyone in between
Maria is good at finding the hidden gems
to share and the amount of information
this woman consumes and can parse down
to the finest detail of what will help
you now blows my mind she makes me look
like the laziest son-of-a-bitch ever and
of course immediately my questions are
how how does she do that how on earth
does she do that and we dig into this in
this interview
really I try to unearth the hidden gems
in her life her workflow it takes me a
few minutes to warm up as it often does
but once we get going we geek out like
crazy and we talk about almost every
aspect of her life her site her business
her workouts her writing her workflow
her tools her workarounds all of it and
I love doing this interview I hope you
love listening to it and for bonus
credit for those of you who are super
curious might have a little extra time
to do some detective work at one point
she mentions that her Facebook fan page
went from a few hundred thousand people
to over two million people without
explanation so if you are able to figure
out why that happened what contributed
to that please let me know on Twitter at
T Farris TFE
Riss I'm dying of curiosity and always
or as always I should say the shownotes
all the links that we mentioned the
tools etc all of that can be found on
the blog at 4-hour workweek dot-com
forward slash podcast 4-hour workweek
dot-com forward slash podcast all
spelled out so you don't need to
scribble away furiously with notes
although you can I will have pretty much
everything that you will need right
there in the show notes so without
further ado please mate
Maria Popova hello ladies and gentlemen
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
I am extremely excited to have a fellow
geek in arms
Maria Popova on the line with me Maria
how are you today
very well thank you thank you for having
me and I appreciate your coaching on the
last name I wasn't sure if it was pop
OVA or Popova I have friends who for
instance in navall or avocado has a
friend it's actually novel but Americans
can't really pull that off so he goes
first of all so I appreciate the the
coaching and I country of immigrants we
have a surprisingly hard time getting
people's original names right right
absolutely it's you know just the sort
of angled sizing of of such a pretty
sort of like a melting pot of different
cultures and you know at the same time I
think it's a reflection of where I spend
a lot of time which is reading and there
are so many words I've embarrassed
myself on many occasions that I've read
dozens or even hundreds of times
especially in scientific literature that
I've never heard pronouncing oh yeah I
call this reader syndrome as somebody
who spends the majority of her waking
hours reading you run into that a lot
especially with sort of cultural icons
last names first names that are spelled
differently than very differently than
they're pronounced it's kind of tragic
comic when you actually find out how
they're pronounced know exactly or it
can be a real revelation I remember when
I was
a young kid I couldn't hit let's say
democracy or aristocracy I could only
save accent and I'd also read it
democracia aristocracy for whatever
reason I couldn't get the emphasis right
but coming back to the the reading and
someone who spends most of their waking
hours reading if if someone asks you and
I'm sure occasionally it happens you
know what do you do for those people
listening who may not be familiar with
you but we'll start with a cocktail
question when someone asks you what do
you do how do you answer that
well I've answered it differently over
the years in part because I think
inhabiting her own identity as kind of a
perpetual process but right now I would
say I read and I write in that order
and in between I do some thinking and I
think about how to live a meaningful
life
basically and if someone then were to go
online and find your work end up at
brain pickings and they're like ah this
is quite interesting what and they've
kind of looked over their shoulder
because they happen to be doing it on
their iPhone at the party and they're
like what is brain pickings how would
you describe how do you typically
describe that it's just the record of
that thinking my personal subjective
private thinking that takes place
between my reading and takes and and the
writing and takes one in writing a
collection of very interesting things
sometimes you know how I've kept those
that are simply put it to folks and
brain pickings for those people
wondering is one of the very few sites
that I end up on constantly and when
people ask me what blogs do you read I
I'm embarrassed in some cases kind of
humiliated to answer that I don't go
really to many blogs consistently and I
think part of the reason is so many of
them are feel compelled to put out very
very timely of-the-moment material that
expires within a few hours and I don't
like the feeling of keeping up with the
Joneses when the Joneses are just sort
of churning out con
and I remember Kathy Sierra at one at
one point told me you should focus on
just-in-time information not just in
case information and which I thought was
very astute and really sort of profound
but there are there are two sites that
come to mind that I end up on quite a
lot brain pickings is one and Sam
Harris's blog yeah is another and I saw
your your review of his latest book
waking well not a review a review
annotated reading if there well I guess
an annotated reading of and I definitely
want to dig into that annotated reading
of waking up which I found really really
impactful for me in a lot of ways it put
words to a lot of vague sort of feelings
or observations that I had for a very
long time talking about reviews so I
pulled a number of my friends and my
readers about different questions they
would love to ask you and a close friend
of mine Chris Sacca he he came back with
what percentage of New York Times
bestsellers can be attributed to your
coverage and I'd be curious to hear you
answer that and then there's sort of a
follow-up but you've you've built this
incredible powerhouse of an outlet for
your whether it's creative musings or
observations and it has a huge influence
on what people read so if you sort of
think of that how would you answer that
question
you're very kind to put it that way as
as Chris but I think one big caveat to
all of that is that the majority of
books that I read and write about or
very old out-of-print things that are
not competing for New Times bestseller
in fact I don't even know if I ever
really I mean perhaps I don't know if
the books that I read have any overlap
and the Venn diagram of things with the
New York Times bestsellers but I suspect
that the reason Chris asked that
question is actually that I met him
through his wife who collaborated with
Wendy MacNaughton the illustrator whose
work I loved and I love
on a book about wine and Sony dad book
ended up and I wrote about it because
it's lovely and sort of profound and
challenges our existing ideas about sort
of sensory experience and I like things
that that take something very
superficial and find something deeper
and something unusual in it but in any
case so I wrote about that book and that
particular piece on green pickings
seemed to do pretty well and I think
perhaps that warped how much
contemporary books I really should have
am interested in but but I would say
that's a minority right and for those
people wondering it's the essential
scratch-and-sniff guide to becoming a
wine expert which was written along with
and the illustrations are wonderful the
Richard Betts was the sommelier who was
part of that and at one point I met with
him because I wanted to try to
deconstruct the master sommelier test
and he said I can show you how to do it
and it was just the pared down sort of
hacked if you will version still of
passing the master sommelier taste was
so intimidating that I couldn't put it
on ice indefinitely but at some point
Richard we will talk again and and form
a game plan the so the the opposite of
course of sort of putting out this
material that expires as soon as it's
out on the vine is putting out what I
think you do very often and that is sort
of timeless timely and timeless I've
heard you call it material where you're
sort of pulling from old sources or
older sources doing pattern recognition
to pull from other areas to talk about
say a theme or or something that still
affects people and I I was I was doing
research for this interview and we met
briefly in New York at an event and I've
been a longtime fan of your work and so
I thought to myself like you know how
much how much digging do I really need
to do and good god you have such an
absolute canon of work out there it is
astonishing I mean it is really all
right it's just the volume of time
really it's been you know I've been
doing this for eight years coming up
actually exactly a month from today
it'll be eight years and I was I was I'm
fascinated by a routine and schedule and
you know reading from of course not not
the always accurate but generally a good
place to start Wikipedia and it says
that brain picking stakes 400 plus hours
of work per month hundreds of pieces of
content per day 12 to 15 books per week
that you're reading how do you CH and I
know I'm asking a handful of questions
that you've been asked before but
sometimes the answer is change and
evolve do and which is why I actually
don't do interviews very frequently
because I find they sort of mmm tend to
kind of cast this as the static thing
that just stays there some sort of
reference point while we're really just
a fluid process and we're constantly
evolving but in any case no definitely
so the question that you've sure been
asked many times but I'll ask again
is how do you choose the books how do
you find / choose the books that you
read this is a huge problem for me
because I am I appetite for reading
outstrips the time that I have and so I
end up actually unfortunately sometimes
finding myself anxious because of the
number of books I've taken on it at any
given point in time so I'd be curious
how you sort of vet the books that you
read well I guess it goes back to that
question of well let me back to I can
just say that I write about a very wide
array of disciplines and eras and
sensibilities because that's what I
think about - anything from art and
science to philosophy psychology history
designed poetry you name it but the
common denominator for me is just this
very
simple question of does this illuminate
some aspect big or small a bad grand
question that I think we all tussle it
every day which is how to live well how
to live a good meaningful fulfilling
life whether that's you know Aristotle's
views on happiness in government or
beautiful art from 12th century Japan or
or Sam Harris's new book anything got it
and the I've read you citing Kurt
Vonnegut before Kurt Vonnegut's one of
my favorite writers of all time I know I
heard your semi calling I think it was
either be interviewed with Kevin Kelly
or with Sam but I actually have a
counterpoint the semicolon okay no no on
so I actually I actually I brought up
the semicolon quote partially as a sort
of wink wink nod ribbing to a friend of
mine named John Roman Ella who has a
tattoo of a semicolon on his I think
it's his for he also has a molecule of
testosterone on the other arm he's a
fascinating guy but the the quote that I
heard you cite that I wanted to dig into
a bit was to Kurt Vonnegut saying right
to please just one person and so my
question to you is when you write is
that still the case and if so who is
that person that you are writing for it
is very much the case I still write for
an audience of one and that's myself
it's like I said it's just the record of
my thought process my way of just trying
to navigate my way through the world and
understand my place in that understand
how we relate to one another how
different pieces of the world relate to
each other and sort of create a pattern
of meaning
out of seemingly unrelated meaningless
information and the sort of intersection
of or transmutation of information into
into wisdom really which is what
learning to live is it's about wisdom so
I and it's interesting too because when
I started bring beginnings like I said
almost eight years ago it started very
much as a private record of my own
curiosity and I shared it with seven
co-workers that I had at the time just
as a little sort of email newsletter
thing and now to think that there are
about 7 million people strangers reading
it every month that's amazing thank you
but and I'm not sort of number dropping
for sale or anything like that but just
to try to articulate how surreal it
feels to me that I still feel like I'm
writing for one person one very sort of
you know inward person but there's also
now the awareness that there are people
looking on and interpreting and and just
relating to this pretty private act and
it's a strange thing to live with and in
no way a bad thing I'm not complaining
about it obviously but it's just
interesting to observe how one relates
to oneself when being looked on by a few
million people yeah definitely and
there's so many so many questions I want
to ask you we might have to do a part
two at some point because I know we have
some time constraints but the where to
even begin this is where I start fraying
at the ends as an interviewer so the the
the first question would be related to
that there's so much temptation to dumb
things down or to go after kind of the
tried-and-true BuzzFeed type headlines
do you ever contend with that temptation
and if if so how do you resist it and I
and this is part of the you know how do
you respond to the expectations of the
crowd or the 7 million people looking on
and I feel this personally sometimes cuz
I have a blog it has you know certainly
by no means the number of monthly
readers that you have you know I'm
somewhere between one and two million
uniques a month usually but thank you
but even at that even at that scale
there are times when I put out something
that I feel is very very important but
on on the dense side and and then it
will sometimes it takes off but but
sometimes it doesn't and and there's a
lot of temptation when for instance I
know you use social media quite a bit
and we'll get to that where I look at
say the retweets of the favorites on
something that's kind of dense and then
I'm like oh god I should just do like
the seven tricks you can you can
actually teach your cat you know and get
500,000 retweets is that something that
you're that ever sort of crosses your
mind and do you ever feel that
temptation well you know it's
interesting because they think anybody
who thinks in public which is what
writing is which is even what art is
it's some sort of putting a piece of
oneself out into the world anybody who
does that struggles with this really
irreconcilable kind of tug-of-war
between wanting to really stay true to
one's experience you know and being
aware that as soon as it's out in the
world there is this notion of the other
audience and you know Oscar Wilde he
very memorably said that a true artist
takes known notice whatever of the
public and that the public are to him
non-existent
and it's very easy to say especially for
somebody as wild who was very prolific
very public almost performative in his
public presence it's very easy to call
this out as a kind of hypocrisy and say
well you can't possibly not care about
the audience given you make your living
through it and sort of perform to it
right but I I think that's a pretty
cynical interpretation I think rather
than hypocrisy it's just this very human
struggle to be seen and to be understood
which is why
all art comes to be because one human
being wants to put something in it to
the world and to be understood for what
he or she stands for who he or she is
and so with that lens I do think it's
hard to say well you know I don't care
about what happens to it out there even
though I write for myself and think for
myself the awareness of the the other
really does change things but I think
perhaps Werner Herzog put it best I just
finished reading this kind of 600 page
interview with him essentially it's a
conversation that a journalist named
Paul Cronin had with him over the course
of 30 years and in one passage Herzog
says something like you know it's always
been important for me to have my films
reach an audience I don't necessarily
need to hear what those audience
reactions are just as long as they're
out there that they're touching though
the films are touching people in some
way and I feel very similarly so with
that in mind I guess to answer your
question rather circuitously
I I don't feel could I quote tempted to
make listicles or to make anything that
I feel compromises my experience of what
I stand for and in part I think the
beauty of the web is that it's a self
perfecting organism but for as long as
it's an ad-supported medium the motive
will be to perfect the commercial
interest to perfect the art of the
BuzzFeed listicle the endless slideshow
the infinitely paginate at article and
not to suspect the human spirit of the
reader or the writer which is really
what I'm interested in yeah no it's I
think it's a very virtuous goal on I you
know I I really admire your sight and
obviously the newsletter and all these
other aspects of it for a lot of reasons
one of them is well I I feel a very sort
of kindred spirit with a lot of the
it seems you have made so for instance I
mean not doing the the slide shows to
rack up page views for some type of CPM
advertising that stuff drives me insane
so if it drives me insane and I assume
that drives my readers insane so I'm not
going to do it or like you say that's so
wonderful that you do that because I
think so much of the cultural crap that
is out there not just on the internet
just in general comes from people who
failed to understand that they should be
making the kind of stuff they want to
exist so if you're a writer write the
things you want to read if you're an
artist paying the things you want to
paint but you want to see painted and I
think the commercial aspect is really
warping that and I really one thing I
really admire about your work in all of
its permutation is from your books - you
know this podcast to say everything is
that there's just the sort of sense that
you just want this to exist it doesn't
exist for any other reason than you
wanted to exist and I think that's
wonderful thank you oh yeah that means a
lot to me and I you know coming back to
the the right to please just one person
it's you know I say I think that it's
it's related to that so in a way it's
you know put the things out into the
world that you would want to consume
yourself or experience yourself number
one secondly just for those people who
haven't heard this anecdote when I was
writing the 4-hour workweek as my first
book I still to this day find writing
very challenging and I wish I could say
it's gotten easier over time but for
whatever reason it it seems not that you
have the in the case of the 4-hour
workweek I you know came out of
undergrad at Princeton and many many
years of pastime asleep but when I wrote
the first few chapters it was really
stilted and pompous and kind of Ivy
League you know we're amused I was
trying to use $10 words we're a 10 cent
word would suffice and be a lot cleaner
so I threw out the first few chapters
that I drafted and this was a major
panic attack moment I was on deadline
and I remember I was in Argentina at the
time and then I went the other way and I
said no no I have to be loose I have to
be funny and so I wrote a few chapters
that were completely slapstick
ridiculous I mean they'd sounded like
three stood
is put on paper so I had to throw out
those few chapters and of course I'm
doubling down on my anxiety at this
point and decided at one point that I
was just going to have a little bit of
yerba maté 82 glasses of wine and no
more than two glasses of Malbec and sit
down and start to write what is that
Malbec is just this wonderful varietal
in South America best known in Argentina
but there's actually some really nice
Malbec wines in Chile they were as I
understand it it was viewed almost as a
garbage grape in Europe but it was
brought by the Italians to bueno
scientists and has developed this
worldwide fame because of its
cultivation in Argentina so there's
there's a lot of sort of there's a lot
of metaphor there that I also like but
drank two of us as a wine sat down and
literally opened up an email client and
started typing the 4-hour workweek as if
I were writing it to two of my closest
friends one was an investment banker
trapped in his own job and he felt like
he couldn't leave because his lifestyle
was swelling to meet his income and then
the other was an entrepreneur sort of
trapped in a company of his own making
and so these two very specific guys in
mind I started to write with just enough
alcohol to take the edge off and that's
how you know I was writing in that case
to please just to people but that's
that's the only way I could make it work
the your schedule so I've I've read of
your schedule but I'd love to hear the
current iteration of that it seems like
you've had a fairly you have a fairly
regimented schedule which would make
sense if you're putting the number of
hours into reading and writing that you
do so what is what is your current day
look like well I'll answer this with a
caveat the one thing I have struggled
with or tried to solve for myself in the
last few years couple years maybe is the
sort of really delicate balance between
productivity and presents and
especially in a culture that seems to
measure our worth or merit or our value
through our efficiency and our earnings
and our ability to perform certain tasks
as opposed to just the fulfillment we
feel in their own lives and the presence
that we take in in the day-to-day and
that's something I've become more and
more apparent to me so I'm a little bit
reluctant to discuss routine as some
sort of holy grail of creative process
because it's just really it's a crutch I
mean routines and rituals help us not
feel like this overwhelming messiness of
just day-to-day life would consume us
it's a control mechanism but that's not
all there is and the kind of thing it
should be in the service of something
greater which is being present with
one's own life so with that in mind my
day is very predictable I get up in the
morning I meditate for between 15 to 25
minutes before I do anything else what
time do you wake up typically exactly 8
hours after I have gone to bed so it
varies I'm a huge proponent of sleep I
think I when I write because what or
when I I guess try to think what I do is
essentially make associations between
seemingly unrelated ideas and concepts
and in order for that to happen you know
those associative chains need to be
firing and when I am sleep-deprived I
feel like I don't have full access to my
own brain which is certainly I'm not
unique in that in any way there's
research showing that our reflexes are
severely hindered by lack of sleep we're
almost as drunk if we sleep less than
half the amount of time would normally
need to function and I think ours is a
culture where we where we where our
ability to get by and very little sleep
as a kind of badge honor badge of honor
that bespeaks work ethic or toughness or
whatever it is but really it's a total
profound failure of priorities and of
self-respect
and I tried to sort of enact that in my
own life by being very disciplined about
my sleep at least as disciplined as
about as I am about my work because the
latter is a product of the capacities
you know cultivated by the former so in
any case so I get up eight hours after I
have gone to bed I meditate I go to the
gym where I do most of my longer form
reading I get back home my breakfast and
I start writing I usually write between
two and three articles a day and one of
them tends to be longer and when I write
I need uninterrupted time so I try to
get the longer one done earlier on in
the day when I feel much more alert so I
don't look at email or anything really
external to the material I'm dealing
with which does require quite a bit of
research usually so it's not like I can
cut myself off from the internet or from
other books but I don't have people
disruptions I guess so anything social
and then I take a short break I'm a
believer in sort of pacing creating a
sort of rhythm where you do very intense
focused work for an extended period and
then you take a short break and then
cycle back you know and then I deal with
any sort of admin stuff like emails and
just taking care of errands and whatnot
and I resume writing and I write my
other article or articles through the
evening I try to have some private time
just later in the day either with
friends or with my partner or just you
know time that is unburdened by
deliberate thought although you can
never unburden yourself from thought in
general and then usually later at night
I either do some more reading or some
more writing or a combination of the two
got it and so a number of follow-up
questions what type of meditation do you
practice currently just guided by pass
on a very very basic
there's a woman named Tara brach who
she's a mindfulness practitioner how do
you spell her last name
Br ACH got it and she's based out of DC
and she was trained as a cognitive
psychologist then the decades of
Buddhist training and and lived in an
ashram and now she teaches mindfulness
but with a very secular lens so she
records her classes and she has a
podcast which is how I came to know her
and every week she does a one-hour
lecture and sort of the philosophies and
cognitive-behavioral you know wisdom of
the ages and then she does a guided
meditation so I her meditations and she
has changed my life perhaps more
profoundly than anybody in my life so I
highly recommend her Tara brach rock yes
and all her podcast is free just two
books out too she's really wonderful
very different person I will have to
check that out and see you're listening
then you have earbuds in when your door
you're listening you're listening to
audio while you meditate yes
and it's interesting she puts one out
every week but I've been using the exact
same one from the summer of 2010 it's
just one that I like and feel familiar
with and it sort of helps me get into
the rhythm so every day I listen to the
exact summer 2010 how does that start
how would people recognize it how does
the audio I think the title is it sounds
cheesy but it is not cheesy I think it's
called smile meditation and I'm sure she
has repeated it in various forms through
the years and other recordings it just
happens to be the one that I you know
have on and on my broken 3G iPhone
without any internet or cell service
which I just use as an iPod and that's
on it awesome that's great answer God
Allah I love digging into the specifics
and when you go to the gym then
to work out are you still using an
elliptical for that or are you are I do
sprints high intensity intervals on the
elliptical and their cardio and I do a
lot of weights and body weights to have
to you do alright but when you're
reading is that on the elliptical yeah
and what type of device if any are you
using for that reading well I prefer
electronic so I use the Kindle app of
the iPad or any PDF viewer because they
bring a lot of archival stuff but the
challenge of course is that because I
read so many older books that are out of
print let alone having digital versions
that's not always possible in case it's
rarely possible unless I'm writing about
something fairly new and so in that case
I just go there with my big tome and my
sticky notes and pens and sharpies and
various annotation analog devices and I
just do that cool all right so I have
that that leads perfectly into the next
question which is what is your
note-taking system look like and how do
you take notes so for instance you're
really good at using excerpts or
quotations pull quotes and I found
myself asking as I was reading this like
how are you gathering all this so that
you can use it later so what is your
note-taking system look like when you
sit in the case of digital and in the
case of hardcopy hmm so with digital
it's very simple I just highlight
passages and I write myself little notes
underneath each that are that have
acronyms that I use frequently for
certain topics or shorthand that I have
developed for myself but reading is
really or understanding really which is
what reading should be a condiment to is
a form of pattern recognition so when
you read a whole book you kind of walk
away with certain takeaways that are
somatically linked and they don't
usually occur you know sequentially so
it's not like you walk away with one
insight from the first chapter one is it
in Chapter it's just sort of this
pattern of the writers thoughts that
that permeate the entire narrative of
the book and so especially as you if you
read as a writer so somebody who not
only needs to walk away with that but
ideally wants to record what those
patterns and themes are that sort of
reading is very different and so what I
end up doing with analog books in
particular and it's sort of hacks and
systems of doing it electronically but
they're imperfect is on the very last
page of each book which is blank usually
right before the end cover I create an
alternate index so I basically list out
as I'm reading the topics and ideas that
that seem to be important and recurring
in that volume and then next to each of
them I start listing out the page
numbers where they occur and on those
pages I have obviously highlighted the
respective passage and I have a little
sort of sticky tab on the side so I can
find it but it's basically an index
based not on key words which is what a
standard book index is based on but
based on key ideas and I use that then
to sort of synthesize what those ideas
are once I'm ready to write about the
book okay I have to get out on this
because I'm so excited now so as it
turns out with analog books I do exactly
literally exactly the same thing I
usually start with an in front inside
cover but I create my own index and of
course they don't have to be in order so
you can sort of list yeah them in any in
my particular case in any in the order I
also will have sort of - a couple of
lines dedicated to pH and pH just refers
to phrasing so if I find a turn of
phrase or wording that I find that's so
cool okay so there's that and then I
have you know Q or Q if I if their
quotes so for instance many books will
have
quotes attributed to other people or
just header quotes in some cases and so
I'll have you know quotes I'll just
write that out and then : and then I'll
list all the page numbers for that
particular sort of category that I'm
collecting in the case of quotes so for
when you're gathering this you mentioned
acronyms and shorthand so besides
beautiful language what are some of the
other acronyms that you use oh they
wouldn't make sense they're just very
private it's like too long to get into
what they stand for my own system is
there one other example that you just
just if you can indulge me one that is I
guess not so much about the contents of
that passage as about its purpose as LJ
which is I have a little sort of labor
of love side project called litter and
jukebox right sure yeah I've seen it
it's yeah it's it's awesome oh thank you
but yeah I do these pairings of passages
from literature would automatically
match song and so sometimes when as I'm
reading a book I would come across a
passage that I think would be great for
that and maybe a song comes to mind and
so I would put lj8
next day but when I go back to what you
said about the external quotes I guess
the author quoting another work I think
those are actually really important and
that goes back to your question about
how I find what to read and I mark those
types of things so for the for the
annotations that are specific to that's
particularly key tab notes are on the
side of the of the pages but when it
there's an external quote something
referencing another work I put a tab at
the very top with the letter F which
stands for find if I am NOT going for
the word with the work or just no letter
if I just want a flag a quote from
something else that I know of and I
think that's actually very important
because the the phenomenon itself not my
annotations of it because literature is
really and I say this all the time it is
the original Internet so all of those
references and citations and allusions
even they're essentially hyperlink
that that author placed to another work
and that way if you follow those you go
into this magnificent rabbit hole where
you start out with something that you're
already enjoying and liking but follow
these tangential references to other
works that perhaps you would not have
come across that way I mean directly and
in a way it's a way to push oneself out
of the filter bubble in a very
incremental way and I've often found
amazing older books that were you know
five or six hyperlink reference is
removed from something I was reading
which led me to something else which led
me something else which led me to this
great other thing so I think that's
that's kind of a beautiful practice yeah
it's the the serendipity of it is so
beautiful when it works out and I lab
give a confession this is really
embarrassing but you know since I was
listening I came across Seneca so Seneca
the younger who's had probably more
impact on my life than any other writer
originally because there I was perusing
it a number of anthologies on minimalism
and simplicity and Seneca kept on
popping up quote Seneca quote Seneca
because it was always one word like
Madonna or and this is gonna be really
embarrassing or like Sitting Bull I
assumed that Seneca was a Native
American elder of some type for probably
a good I assumed he was a Native
American elder for probably a good year
or two before I realized he was like man
first you got to do your homework that
like he got a dig in and then at that
point is when I really sort of jumped
off the cliff into a lot of his writings
which I still to this day revisit on an
almost his the shortness of life oh so
good so perhaps the best
Festo and I had paid this modern word
sort of buzzword but I used it
intentional he said the best manifesto
for our current struggle with this very
notion of you know productivity versus
presence and how much are we really
mistaking the doing for the being you
know and and and it's amazing that
somebody wrote this millennia ago before
there was internet before there was the
things we call distractions today and
and yet he writes about the exact same
things just in a different form yeah the
exact same things and the way that if
I'm trying to use Seneca as a gateway
drug into philosophy I won't use the
p-word first of all with most people
because philosophy smacks of I think it
calls to mind for a lot of people the
sort of haughty pompous college student
in Good Will Hunting in the bar scene
who's like reciting you know Shakespeare
without giving any type of I agree with
the notion that those are its
connotations today and people have a
resistance but I think that's all the
more reason to use it heavily and to use
it intelligently and to reclaim it and
to get people to understand that
philosophy whatever form it takes is the
only way to figure out how to live the
other thing else that we take away from
anything is a set of philosophies
essentially I agree no I totally agree
so but I usually if I'm gonna lead
people there I try to to to with with
Seneca because I think he's very easy to
read compared to a lot of say at least
the Stoics or that's actually not even
fair compared to a lot of philosophers
who who have been translated from Greek
most of his writing I believe was
translated from Latin which tends to be
just an easier jump from English so it's
very easy to read night what I tell
people is you know start off with some
of his letters and you'll find that you
could just as easily replace these Roman
names like Luke Ilyas and
and so on with like Bob and Jane or you
know pick your contemporary name if of
choice and it they're all as relevant
now as they were then
so I'm going to come back to the sort of
performance versus presence which I
think of oftentimes as these
achievements Plitt or balance or maybe
neither but before we get there I want
to put a put a bow on the note taking
with your electronic note-taking so
you're using the Kindle app you're
taking highlights where do you go from
there are there any other what is what
is the sort of workflow look like from
there and are there any any particular
types of software or apps or anything
like that that you use often I mean
honestly I feel like that problem has
not been solved at all in any kind of
practical way so the way that I do it is
basically a bunch of hacks using
existing technologies but I don't think
or perhaps I'm just unaware but I don't
think there's anybody designing tools
today for people who do serious heavy
reading there just isn't anything that I
know and so what I do is I highlighted
the in the Kindle app and the iPad and
then Amazon has this function that you
can basically see your Kindle notes and
highlights on the desktop on your
computer I go to those I copied them
from that page and I paste them into an
Evernote file to sort of just have all
of all of my notes in a specific book in
one place but sometimes I would also
take a screen grab of a specific iPad
Kindle app Kindle page with my
highlighted passage and then email that
screen grab into my Evernote email
because Evernote has as you know optical
character recognition so when I searched
within it it's also going to search the
text in that image I don't have to wait
until I finish the book and explore all
my notes and and also it's the
the formatting is kind of shitty on the
the Kindle notes on the desktop we can
see all your notes so if you copy them
they paste them to Evernote with this
really weird formatting so it tabulates
each next notes indented to the right so
it's sort of this cascading long
cascading thing that's just more and
more to the right of the soup yeah
that's horrible it's like an email
thread it's like an email right except
there's no actual hierarchy these are
all you know and so if you want to go
fix it you have to do it manually would
then Evernote and you know I I read you
know on the Verna Hertzog book for
example which is 600 pages I have
thousands of notes so imagine thousands
of tabulations until the last one is so
narrow and long that it's just like
unreadable so hence my point about just
there is no viable solution that I know
got it okay so let me just because I
this may or may not help for me it was a
huge shift in how I manage Evernote cuz
I mean I'm looking at this list of
questions and I'm not reading entirely
off on script but I have a collection of
questions they never note right now and
one one of the things I realized about
formatting and transposing things from
say the you know my Kindle page if you
if you log into your Amazon account
through and all amazon.com or copying
pasting from many different places is
going to I don't know if you've tried
this but edit and either paste and match
style or paste as plain text and it
tends to remove all of that headache I'd
seen nine times out of ten so if you the
problem with that I did try that once
but when you remove the style it makes
all the metadata look the same as the
text so and every highlighted passage I
also have my own note I see
got it plus plus you know Amazon's own
thing that says add note read redid this
location Alicia
and so it all merges it and becomes just
hideous you know
I wonder I wonder what to do there yeah
I used to take notes and drop them into
TextWrangler which is used for coding a
lot just to remove the formatting and
then put it into Evernote yeah it's true
though there's gotta be a solution and
the thing is Evernote
I love Evernote I've been using it for
many years and I could probably not get
through my day without it but it has an
API which means so buddy can build this
you know wait so like I even thought I
mean I was at one point so desperate and
so frustrated which I think is the the
duo that causes all innovation you know
desperation and frustration I thought
maybe I should just save up some money
and offer like a scholar or like a grand
for a hackathon for somebody to solve
this for me yeah that's a great idea I'm
sort of contemplating that ok well we'll
talk about that separately I think
that's something that we could
absolutely explore and for all of you
programmers coders out there please take
a look this is actually not as rare and
issues you might expect one question for
you on the Kindle highlights I've run
into this
you mentioned the werner herzog book and
having you know thousands of highlights
i've have you run into instances where
you'll you'll read an entire book you're
super impressed or not but you
regardless you have hundreds of
highlights and you go to look at those
highlights and you're restricted to only
so yeah it's like 200 highlight 81
available right so how often does that
happen to you because that's happened to
me where I've taken so much time to
meticulously highlight stuff and then
I'm only able to see 25% and it's so
infuriating and I think it's a
limitation that is determined by the
publisher yes it is and I'll tell you
why it hasn't happened to me much it
happens to me occasionally but that's a
DRM thing digital listeners who don't
like acronyms digital rights management
thing that has that is fairly new so
that is the case with more recently
published books but if you read you know
the digitized version of say you know
Alan Watts that was published originally
40
years ago there's no such problem unless
the publisher now is like reclaiming
rights and doing a whole new thing but
because I read so much less out of sort
of newly published material I don't run
into it often but you know there is a
way to very laborious Lee you know deal
with it which is you can still open that
passage in your Kindle app on desktop so
it can go for back for me and it will
let you highlight and copy those
passages paste them into your Evernote
in between the missing parts but it's
obviously not abusive I have done that
and it's so horrible because you also
get the like excerpted from that are
like three lines mm-hmm everyone sit
just publishers if you're listening to
this you are making it harder for people
like Maria of seven million uniques per
month to share your stuff so please up
your threshold do you have anybody
helping you with brain pickings or is it
just you the actual reading and writing
obviously is just me but as of about ten
months ago I have an assistant Lisa it
was absolutely wonderful and she just
helps me with admin steps that has to do
with my travel or email or scheduling
things that I feel is weighing me down
so much I operate so much out of a sense
of guilt for sort of letting people down
or and as you know I'm sure when you get
to a point where the demands are just
incomparable with what you can even look
at then you kind of need to have help in
order not to either go insane or live
with a constant guilt over not
addressing things so and was there
particularly oh and I also have a copy
of this wonderful older lady I hired to
do my proofreading she's great I am
that's all I can say
I think proofreading is really really
important and I'm constantly embarrassed
if I have a typo which you know as you
know as a writer you cannot prove
your own work it just your brain just
does not see the air so we made in the
first place or the majority of them and
so and people are kind of merciless they
think somehow that a typo makes you lazy
or I don't even know there's no kind of
compassion for the humanity that
produces something as human as a typo
right despite how mechanical the term
itself seems which is sort of ironic but
in any case oh yes I have my assistant
for admin and my copy editors were just
proofing and what platform is is brain
pickings on at the moment what is it
what's the the technology behind it and
I know that I've heard you mention
WordPress before is it on is it still on
WordPress it is I was gonna make a joke
on her about how the technology is
called corpus callosum but the actual
technology is very Sam Harris friendly
joke the the so when you're working with
say your copy editor do you give you or
copy editor admin access to WordPress
and she'll go in proofread it and then
schedule or publish what's the process
it's a very again super sort of hack
together process which is every night I
email her the articles from the preview
page on WordPress I just copy that and
paste it into a body email and I send it
to her and then she sends him the
corrections for your email god I mean
like I said she's not very I would say
tech savvy I mean I'm sure she's a
wonderful learner so I'm sure she would
totally learn how to do it if I had gave
her admin access but between that and
the fact that I write in HTML so I
really don't like the WYSIWYG I hate it
actually I think it's just easier to do
it via email because then she can like
highlight the word and sometimes she
would make suggestions that are more
stylistic and I I would like to have the
final say in those because very often I
want to keep it the way that I
because boys so I find email works just
fine got it okay no I'm always
fascinated because I I will use while
when I was when I was hosting wordpress
elsewhere I'm also in WordPress I would
use the share a draft plug-in to share
drafts with people I'm I'm now on
WordPress VIP which has a it has a
sharing function where people can leave
feedback in a sidebar that runs
alongside the article itself which is
pretty cool oh that's cool I should
actually look into that I think that's
what I have - there were Presby I see
the WordPress I don't even know what the
that function is - I am kind of I mean
for somebody who writes on the web I'm I
don't really yeah I sometimes only learn
about things through friends I think
yeah that's that's how I learned about a
lot of this stuff and the the other
option that I've used quite a lot is and
as much as I hate word and I really do I
love the track changes feature and I
just find it more user friendly for a
lot of folks and then having them use
something that's cloud-based like Google
Docs just because I operate so much
offline to try to get anything done yeah
I mean that's what a lot of people
suggest in what crime I interfere
actually asked originally but I do not
own Microsoft products on principle and
I just gonna go with it okay no that
makes sense and your assistant what was
what was the sort of defining moment the
straw that broke the camel's back when
you were like you know what like what
was the day we're just like [ __ ]
enough of this like I need to get
somebody stat I mean what when did you
actually make the decision it wasn't so
much that I made the decision as the
decision was very strongly lovingly but
strongly sort of pushed on me by my
partner who one day said you you are
using so much time on things that are
just so menial and you should not and
because I was really stressing to a
point of
just driving myself crazy and I think a
lot of it has to do with the fact that
I'm always have been very independent I
you know moved away from my parents
house when I was 18 paid my way through
school lived always by myself and he
just had this Emerson like an obsessive
self-sufficiency and self-reliance that
to a point of pathology where it was to
my own detriment and the notion of
outsourcing felt to me on some level
almost like an admission of weakness
sure it's ridiculous I think that's I
know and it's the strange thing the
disorienting thing is that I think we
intellectually know that's not the case
that it's actually a lot of strength to
be able to delegate and to sort of divvy
up control according to a hierarchy of
priorities but on some sort of cyclin
motional level it is just death to
consider that you cannot do something on
your own anymore and of course I mean
it's interesting in terms of how brain
cooking's evolved which has always been
very organic so the the sort of you know
eight year thing that has happened it
went from being a little newsletter that
contained five links no text like five
links to five things that I found very
interesting and then it went to sort of
five links with a little paragraph about
each about why this thing is interesting
and important and then it was you know
not not a little paragraph but a little
like one page piece and then it became
not one not five things every Friday but
three things every day of the week
pretty long form in the thousands of
words you know and I foolishly and they
Eve Lee thought that I could just have
the same sort of operational framework
despite the enormous swelling of just
the volume of the writing and that's
unreasonable it's completely
unreasonable so at one point last fall
as the sort of seventh birthday of brain
pickings approaching my partner was just
like please like consider and yeah I
oh I'm sorry I didn't mean to cut you
off I was just I'm always curious to ask
how did you how did you find this
particular system that you ended up with
well she's wonderful she's a
professional sort of personal assistant
that's had this type of job for the 20
years she's just a wonderfully warm and
and just generous person but also has
such doggedness about things and just
work ethic it's unbelievable and he
always have the sense that she's looking
out for your best interest and in the
most magnanimous kind of way towards you
but also the most warmly non no-bullshit
way outwardly towards the world
demanding things from you and having
this buffer it's really really great
yeah and did was she how did you track
her down how did the two of you get
connected I just a recommendation she's
been working for somebody who's a very
trusted dear person for a long time so
now she works for both of us and that
person reach out to you did you reach
out to her I'm always curious about the
specifics because of the way that I
found one of my first assistants and we
worked together for many years was
anytime I had a really fantastic
interaction with someone's assistant I
would say hey I know this is off topic
but you've been awesome to deal with do
you have you know twin brother twin
sister somebody who does what you do as
well as you do it that you could
recommend it because I need some help
and I just did that over and over again
and eventually one of the said well
actually I worked for multiple clients
so we could talk about it and that's how
we ended up working together but what
what was the the introduction was made
by the person so we I I had met her at
least in my assistant I'd met her just
socially many times before and so
eventually when the time came for me to
consider like she just like we said up a
meeting we talked and she was really
into it and she'd been reading brain
pickings and I asked made sure it
wouldn't be too much on her plate cuz
she's also I mean she's superwoman least
a superwoman she is the mother of two
kids one of whom
is now her first year in high school and
the other one his first year in college
so he how's that on her plate to and but
she's very like I said very dogged very
sort of dedicated and she was like I can
do it and I'd like to do it and I was
like great let's roll onward so with
with your assistant if you were to do an
80/20 analysis of to the 8th the you
know the 20% of tasks that take up 80%
of her time what what are the types what
would those look like what is the vast
majority of her time spent on so mm-hmm
a lot of it as I guess coordinating
travel and things but I'm trying to
really I mean I have this new ish
commitment to really not do any speaking
of commercial conference anymore but to
speak to students because I think it's
important and what it takes out of me
which is a lot speaking takes out a lot
of me because I'm a writer and I also
don't really recycle talks I like to
write something original and when it's a
commercial conference it just doesn't
add up for me what I get out of it
because I usually donate my Commission's
due to the local public library whatnot
but what students it is worth my time if
I this way even one journalism student
from going into buzz worthy lands you
know after graduation that's worth it to
me and so even though I've scaled back
on the speaking speaking I now getting
like all these college requests and so
that takes so much time especially
coordinating because a lot of them are
organized by sort of student volunteers
and they're kind of still learning what
it means to you know schedules and
deadlines and advance notice and so
releases sort of wrangling that and
another big part and I should also
mention that the evolution of what I've
been able to delegate has been has sort
of organically happened originally I
just really didn't know what to give her
I felt like I had to do all of it
because I didn't know how to explain it
to her to do and but it's just a great
learner and I'm
to delegate more but another thing
because my site runs on donations I
wanna I should have make an effort to
send handwritten thank-you cards to just
at this point randomly picked donors
every month and so I have her sort of
export those names and emails for me and
just give me like just prepare envelopes
and all those types of things that I
could not spend too much time on the
actual admin of the mailing and do you
operate do you communicate exclusively
the email or do you use soft other types
of software email email and text email
and text so no project management
software at this point no sort of base
camp or a sauna or anything like that
yeah I don't that would make like some
sort of commercial organization you know
I still have so much resistance to the
fact that I even have to deal with these
things
yesterday Oscar Wilde hypocrisy a bad
party what a couple of a couple of quick
ones so the first is when you when you
lift do you tend to have the same
workout what do what is your what is
your weight lifting look like it's
changed a lot in the last year and a
half I've prioritized body weight stuff
heavily no pun intended
that was actually total inadvertent this
how language how we think in language
that's so funny
but I provide body weight stuff and so I
do pull-ups push-ups and that sort of
thing it also depends on where I do my
work have my gym has my building has a
sort of gym like a you know one of those
residential gyms but I also have a
membership at a larger probably I think
the best gym in New York I love it but
I'm only there a few days a week so it
just depends on where I do it and what I
do and if you had to pick one besides
the elliptical if you had to pick one
bodyweight exercise to hold you over
let's say you're traveling for a few
months you can only pick one bodyweight
exercise what would it be well it would
be pull-up but you can't always find a
place to do it so I just do
usually elevated push-ups to my feet on
a bench or bed or some like a step or
something and just push-ups cool a great
little hack for pulling motions while
traveling is putting your feet on a
chair and going underneath a table to do
basically inverted rows you know it's
actually very helpful for traveling is
plyometrics plyometrics and TRX is
actually quite handy there's a reason
it's just not my thing get into it yeah
the thing is here's the thing so if I am
forced by circumstances to do a workout
that is not my preference I very much
like to be able to do something else
while doing it such as listening to
podcasts which is what I do well while I
do weights of the gym anyway and there
are certain types of movements that it's
just a hassle to have the headphones and
it's just like not brace truth so I
actually carry a weighted jump rope with
me when I travel in case there's nowhere
to do sprints which is my plan B for
cardio and then Plan C is just jumping
skipping rope yeah you're intense I love
it the I remember yeah you know I wanted
to every time I mean this is so silly
but I was so obsessed with Bulgarian
Olympic weightlifters for a very long
time that whenever I meet Bulgarians are
people who at any point of lived in
Bulgaria I want to talk about but it's
not know exactly it's kind of like you
know like oh you're from Switzerland let
me talk to you about the guys in the
Rococo commercial they're like no we
don't talk about that stuff I'm your
cousin
Yeah right right you must know like no I
actually don't like I know I went to X Y
& Z college but there are 5000 people he
doesn't always work out you mentioned
the donations I want to talk about the
site so it appears and I and I dug
around a bit but it appears that you
have no comments or dates on your posts
is that accurate
I don't have comments I do have dates
there in the URL this is the date
they're in the URL but they're not in
the post they're in the URL structure
but they're not in the x-blade post
itself yeah so the reason for that is
because I do think we live in an
enormous Li news fetishistic culture and
the reason I do what I do is precisely
to decondition that because we think
that if something is not news and it's
not at the top of the search results at
the top of the feed because all feeds
are reverse chronology and you know
there's an implicit hierarchy of
importance to that we think if it's not
at the top it's not important and you
know you would understand you know
writing about Seneca it really doesn't
matter what the date stamp on it is but
I think that this culture conditions is
so much people when they see a date
stamp they sort of think oh this was
like 2 years old oh and it's really you
know 2,000 years old
part of academics actually use brain
clippings to reference so I constantly
get things this another thing that Lisa
deals with like requests from textbooks
for citations or you know whatnot and
those people actually need the dates so
I've made it so that if you actually
look it's kind of easy to see or I can
just tell them when they write and ask
me what the date is look in the URL but
it's just not one of those immediate
things that slaps you over the head like
a newspaper front page yeah definitely I
actually have done the same thing for
quite a few years and if you if you go
to any permalink so if you go if you get
linked to any of my posts directly on
the blog the date is there in the URL
but also at the very bottom of the post
after the related links so for the same
reason because there's so much bias
against older material and I think some
of my older stuff is I mean it depends
on the person obviously in the context
but it's it's an easy way to have a high
sort of abandonment rate is to timestamp
the comments did you ever have comments
or have you never had comment I did and
then I was like you know what I kind of
feel like Hertzog does I don't really
care to hear I mean I do write for me
I'm very glad and by people who are in
anyway
after touch but the comments I was
getting I was I've been fortunate enough
not to really get any you know trolling
or anything like that but they were kind
of vacant or people trying to plug their
own thing or spam and it was taking more
of my time that was worth and so instead
of made my contact information very
easily accessible so if someone has
something of substance and urgency to
say which is I think the two things that
can help people to reach out they'll do
it via email behind their own name and
not anonymously and then I mean I do get
a lot of a lot of emails from readers
and those are valuable you know but I
didn't really care for comments now the
flip side of that is that now that I
have the Facebook page having if
something mysterious happened with the
bring pickins Facebook page last
follower it just started growing so fast
I've no idea why you know I was gonna
ask you about that because if you if you
look at say that your Twitter follower
growth versus your Facebook growth the
Facebook just kind of took off yeah it
was in about October of last year and it
went from 250,000 to now I think I don't
know I should point something million
close to three maybe so more than
tenfold in less than a year I have no
idea why I've done nothing differently
I'm very I don't really enjoy Facebook I
do it reluctantly because I know I get a
lot of emails from readers elsewhere in
the world who actually use Facebook as
their primary thing and there's such
sweet notes you know people who just are
stimulated and inspired and moved in a
way that perhaps they wouldn't be if
they hadn't read that piece about some
random thing that I read and heard about
and I think it would be selfish of me to
just sort of disable Facebook because I
hate it but the point of it is that you
can't you have comments on there and
Lisa my assistant actually that's
something I delegated her a few months
ago just to completely deal with them I
can't I can't deal with them I can't and
not for any other reason that I have
complete allergy to people pronouncing
their so-called opinions without having
actually digested or even engaged with
the things so people would comment on
the basis of like
a thumbnail image or the title make
really outrageously inaccurate comments
clearly not having read the piece and
this kind of snapped reaction thing that
I think social media to a large extent
perpetuate I can deal with it just it's
like a psychic drain like I can't even
explain it just I can't so anyway so so
that would explain that would answer one
of my questions which is in your header
picture on facebook you have this should
be a cardinal rule of the internet end
of being human if you don't have the
patience to read something don't have
the hubris to comment like [ __ ] or
anything the point I mean you know it's
interesting because I think a lot about
criticism and the notion of criticism
and and why it's so hard for anybody and
I don't think that people have a hard
time with criticism because another
person this agrees with or dislikes what
they're saying they really have a hard
time when they feel misunderstood like
the other person does not understand who
they are or what they stand for in the
world and 99% of the time and you
actually touch on this in your
conversation with Sam Harry I swear to
say that his ideas are not as
controversial as people think when they
don't actually understand what they are
but the main source of anguish is not
being seen for who you are not being
understood and this kind of reactive
culture where people comment without
taking the care to understand what
you're expressing who you are when you
stand for
it is so toxic it is so toxic to leaders
to writers to us as a culture and I just
don't know how to get around it other
than just having instructed Lisa to be
just merciless about banning people and
deleting comments that are just not mmm
there's no humanity there's no patience
there's no thinking in them so I mean
you know anybody who writes online I
think feel similarly that this is kind
of my home and the people come and be
idiots in it then they're not
welcome there yeah yeah no I actually
used the exact same analogy I say look I
have you might especially on my blog I
view the comments is my living room and
if you come into my house for the first
time and get raging drunk and like take
your you know put your feet up on my
table with your shoes but you're not
gonna be invited back you're gone you
know so is is your assistants job as it
relates to Facebook then primarily
calling the herd and just removing the
the idiots or does she have what are
what are other instructions if any are
there things that she passes to you are
there things that she responds to no I
don't I don't really care what people
say again to the point that if people
have something of substance and urgency
they will reach out and I'm then very
happy to hear from actual humans and
engage in a human dialogue which I do
but I really care about you know the
comments on Facebook I just don't want
them depressing me when I go on the page
because I put my own things on there you
know Lisa doesn't put the actual
postings and I also don't want them
creating a culture that is antithetical
to the very reason why I do what I do
which is a kind of faith in the human
spirit I mean that's where I come from I
am a cautious one sometimes but an
optimist about the so-called human
condition and anybody who craps on that
without having even given a chance to
the thoughts that that speak to that to
those ideals which is what my articles
are record of then I will want them gone
you know and so her instructions are
just you know banned people who are
offensive to others sort of in a vicious
way as opposed to just having rational
discourse of disagreement ban people who
are ignorant and and have not read the
thing and have some very scandalous or
not even scandalous sort of sincerity
and sensationalist take on it clearly
not understanding the nuance because I
mean a culture of news as I say often a
culture without nuance then yeah so that
that's basically it help me stay sane
when I look at them that's her that's
her past it's not you lose my mind
just exasperation when people is
impatient no and I you know I really
respect that because another reason that
I read brain pickings as opposed to
other sites and I feel comfortable going
there is that I feel it is a stronghold
of positivity and optimism in in a lot
of respects so kudos the email actually
before we get email I've read that you
schedule your Twitter and Facebook which
would make sense because you're prolific
if that if that's still the case what do
you use to schedule that social media I
use buffer for Twitter and I use just my
hands for Facebook but again I mean this
goes back to the same inner struggle of
I do want to be reading and writing for
myself so why do I have the compulsion
to put so much of it out there and I
just sell flagellate over that because
on some level it does seem like a form
of hypocrisy but then I do think about
the people that email me from India and
Pakistan and South Africa and Korea and
wherever that actually that's how they
connect and I think if I'm putting in
the amount of time that I do into into
what I do even if I do it for myself I
might as well just harness that time
anyway if it benefits somebody else's
journey you know and say oh I do it
because of that mostly definitely and I
think that while it's fine to write for
yourself if you if you keep the value of
what you write to yourself when it could
benefit a lot of other people then I
think that's actually it could be viewed
as a selfish act right so the more I
think that there's particularly when
you're curating in the way that you do
and you're saving people thousands of
hours of searching by distilling a lot
of these concepts well I would argue
that the benefit the value is not even I
mean what I do is kind of the antithesis
of search it's a discovery of things
that
ideally one would not have come across
within the usual parameters of one's
filter bubble right so sort of a lot of
the people that that I hear from for
example you know just this week to
choose the Seneca example actually just
this week I heard from this guy who was
an IT person trained as a physicist end
up doing IT and said the Seneca the
shortness of life piece really will
really put everything in perspective
I've never really read philosophy never
been interested in it never looked for
it but it just cut in the middle of what
I'm struggling with right now in my own
life you know and it's kind of it gives
you pause to hear that from people
definitely agreed on on email the if you
go to your contact page you recommend
email charter org and I'm very curious
to hear if people actually follow the
email charter II we in terms of the the
email that you receive do people
actually pay attention to that yeah they
do and I'm so grateful and I mean but
the majority of them do you know some
people who reach out with the intention
of self promoting there's usually you
know laziness to people who self promote
for the sake there of you know so they
don't they don't usually follow but
people who actually care to have a
conversation and to engage are very
courteous and very sort of mindful of
what I've asked except for publicists
who are never yeah right well I mean I
suppose if they're flying on autopilot
and just blasting out a template your
blog dear blogger you know would I get
very often which I think it's actually
hilarious people who don't even bother
to read the name of the site so they
addressed me dear Brian outcomes wanna
be the pinnacle of this was when last
year at one
point I opened my physical mailbox in my
building my home and I found this bundle
from the USPS but like with an elastic
band around it of mail for somebody
named Brian Pickens school is didn't
Long Beach CA or youth do I get and
somehow that stuff got forwarded to me
because I guess the guy either moved in
the USPS like somehow look things up and
I didn't even know it was such a sort of
mystery and metaphor for what I deal
with online how can you ask the public
not to so I used to have a company ages
ago called brain quicken and I had I got
a telemarketing call one evening ever
and asked I goes hi uh sorry if you're
if I'm interrupting is this Brian and I
go excuse me and he goes Brian Brian
chicken and I'm like Brian chicken I was
like no and take me off your list
goodbye he God so on the on the on the
email and pitching side of things or
just on the pitching side of things how
on earth do you deal with not just cold
enquiries but how do you deal with
writer friends or acquaintances who are
writers that you don't want to be rude
to who want you to read their books how
do you polite decline that stuff and
maybe maybe you don't get a lot of it I
get a ton of it and the fact the matter
is like not everyone is is able to put
the time or effort into writing a good
book so inevitably if I get 10 books
from decent or good friends
some of them are gonna be terrible and I
don't have the time necessarily or the
inclination to read them all how do you
deal with that type of situation
well I guess they deal first and
foremost by controlling not the outcome
but the the cause which is your circle
of friends and acquaintances I'm very
selective about the people I surround
myself with and I'm I'd like to thank
friendly to pretty much everybody that I
need
but my circle of actual friends is
really close and really tight and people
who are just you know when the sky
crumbles they're gonna be there and
we're there for each other and so with
that in mind I think there is a certain
boundary that you have to put up
beforehand - I guess manage social
expectations in a way and - for those
people my friend friends in large part I
mean I should mention that the majority
of my close friends including my partner
- or people that I have met just through
what I do so there's already the self
selection of sensibility and ideals and
you know I I think would become a
centripetal force for the kinds of
people we want to be and surround
ourselves with those types of people
William Gibson has a wonderful word for
it he calls it personal micro culture
and even when you said early on the
kinship of spirit I think that's so
important so which is the long one that
way to say that when and if those inner
circle people put a book out it's a
guarantee that I will like it because of
who they are and so then I'm more than
happy to support it I mean the the book
that we started with the scratchansniff
guide to wine Wendy the illustrator is
precisely that type of person somebody
who I met through what each of us does
and she's now one of my closest human
beings you know and so of course I'm
gonna support her work but not because
I'm being nepotistic about it but
because that's the pre requirement that
I am moved by her work and respect it
and and love it and that's how we became
friends but outside of that inner circle
I do
I think acquaintances know that there's
no such expectation and when I do get
such requests it's a matter of well did
the person do their homework and knowing
what I actually think and write about it
was very often I'm sure you get that to
get such things that are just so outside
of what you do in which case I don't
feel compelled to respond because if
they didn't put in the time to
understand what I'm interested in why
should I put in the time to explain to
them why this is not a fit yeah that's a
great way to put it I need to embrace
that more I think that's an area where I
carry a lot of guilt yeah but guilt it's
interesting because guilt is kind of the
flipside of prestige and they're both
horrible reasons to do things so often
we would agree as humans not just you
and me just anybody would agree to do
things because they sound prestigious
itself in some way you know and and
equally avoid things because of the
guilt thing or do things because the
guilt thing but sort of the whole
Buddhist thing about a version of you
know avoidance and aversion and making
decisions based out of either fear which
is what guilt is it's the fear of
disappointing somebody and then feeling
disappointed in yourself or out of sort
of grasping for you know approval or a
claim which is what doing things for
prestigio is I think either of those are
really bad reasons to do things and yet
they motivated us a lot or at least they
sort of lurk in the back of the mind
constantly and it is a real practice to
try to decondition that definitely know
I like I like I like what you said about
why I put in the effort to explain why
it's not a fit if they haven't done the
homework to determine if it is a fit I
think that's a great way to put it I
want to ask and I I know we don't have
too much time left so hopefully sometime
someday we can do a follow-up part two I
think that'd be a blast I'll bring some
all back if you actually I can introduce
you to it firsthand but the the
donations I'm very fascinated by the the
add free donation approach and just take
just two to keep it simple if you had to
choose say 20% of the options you're
currently offering which would you
choose and why in other words you have
no know so I'll explain or two or three
so you so people can make one-time offer
they can make a one-time single
contribution they can let me simplify
that question or they can become a
member and donate you know seven three
ten or twenty five dollars a month
what I'm trying to ask without being
improprieties or making you feel
uncomfortable is what is working best
when you're asking people for donations
you know assuming that it's working if
if someone were to offer one or two
options instead of four options per
month or the the single contribution
versus the membership or the membership
versus the single contribution what
would your advice be to people well I
will preface this with a caveat that I
use PayPal for donations and I can for
the life of me figure out how to
actually like look at the data and get
any sort of real reason all of it it's
so antiquated their export tools and
such and I'm not that interested I would
slice them you know days into looking
into it so I can tell you sort of my
intuitive interpretation yeah and by the
way the only reason these options are as
they are also is also the reason why I
don't have an ad-supported site which is
I just asked myself what would I like to
read as a reader well I would like could
an ad-free site and how would I like to
support that well I'd like to have a few
options you know just because I don't
want to you know be sort of complying to
something and so I just just pulled it
out of the hat basically with these
tears and I've just left them on since I
put them on they seems to work you know
whatever and originally my sense was
that the one time donation is accounted
for much more but I'd never actually
analyzed it because I think I see the
alerts that come from PayPal and
sometimes people would send really large
one-time donations like things that are
totally humbling and enormous ly
generous and I think those kind of you
you kind of weigh them somehow is more
than the cumulative snub of the smaller
donations so I thought that one timers
work much more but then and I'm pretty
sure that must have been the case
earlier on right but and I've had the
recurring ones I've had the one-time
donations for as long as I can remember
for as long as I basically needed to
start making money for the site because
by the way running the site cost me
several times my rent
like all the costs associated with it
it's like crazy so at one point I got to
a point where I had to make money I said
I don't want to do ads I don't believe
in that I'll have just donations and I
didn't even think of recurring ones at
the time that was years ago and then my
friend max Linsky who runs long-form
gorg or having tea and he said well why
didn't she like push the recurring ones
more cuz it's working really great for
us and at that point I had the option
but it was buried somewhere on my like
donation about page or something and so
like okay so I put it in the sidebar and
that was that we want to say maybe 2011
and it started occurring slowly and so
this past year when I did my taxes I
very reluctantly went to deal with all
the PayPal tools to get the data out
basically and I actually had Lisa pull
all the excels and whatnot and then I
did the tally to see and to my surprise
the recurring ones which are very small
individual amounts actually were
two-to-one ratio to the one-time
donations Wow and I don't know at what
point a tipped over but I think because
of the scale and just how many people
have these tiny tiny donations that they
contribute every month I mean that's
such an active commitment and it's so
generous you know that they add up and I
my guess is that as time goes on because
the recurring ones have only been
available for the last like two and a
half three years whatever they would
become by far the larger sort of
financial support compared to the single
ones sure I know that makes sense the if
you had to choose and of course this is
hypothetical but if you had to choose
two of the amounts to leave in the
drop-down so you have seven dollars a
month three dollars ten dollars
twenty-five if you had to choose two of
those to leave up which would you choose
oh I have no idea I'm probably just the
mathematical logical choice the two
middle was that there that three and ten
okay cool
no just very curious about this kind of
thing I think I think you've approached
the blog in a very authentic way with
the content and
I can't emphasize strong strongly enough
what you just said which is you you base
what you do on what you would like or
dislike as a reader in the case of
something with with text it doesn't have
to be super complicated it doesn't have
to be doing tons of analytics for months
before you make a decision just ask
yourself would this annoy the [ __ ] out
of me if so don't do it would I love
this if so try it out every decision has
been that way and actually in the last
couple years I've been getting really
annoyed
I mean brain thinking is a pretty sort
of lo-fi site as you can see it's very
super simple basic but I've been getting
annoyed that it doesn't load very well
on my iPhone when I want to look at
something or pull something up to
reference or iPad I think my friend
Scott Belsky who runs the hands he's a
great guy and he's been sort of a very
generous donor just supporting and you
know and one time he pulls me aside that
was like a thing in february/march and
she's like you know how much I love
brain things but like the site sucks we
couldn't say it in that way but he was
super sweet about it and like he offered
to connect me with this guy that he knew
that I could hire to do a responsive
design and I always have this resistance
to making these sort of technological
improvements because then I feel like I
don't want to be a media company like I
don't want to be a BuzzFeed but at the
end of the day I as a reader and as a
sort of engage or with that experience
was being annoyed right myself so now
I'm in the middle of releasing like a
simple responsive site that is actually
easy to read on your phone and so yeah
it's a fair insulation prevail again
it's so so worth it it took me let's see
it only took me three Oh God seven years
to get a mobile version of the site
ready to go which I just launched a
month or two ago so better late than
never I suppose well Maria this has been
a blast
I really appreciate you taking the time
if someone were to want to explore brain
pickings
what what are a few articles you might
suggest that they start with a few posts
well since we talk about it so much the
Seneca piece about the shortness of life
fairly short piece there was a PC I did
a couple of years ago which was less
about it was not about a specific book
just sort of things that I've been
thinking about for a long time this
disconnect between purpose and prestige
and why we do things and I forget what
it's called I think it's called how to
do what you love or some other how to
find your purpose and do what you love
and it was sort of an assemblage of
thoughts on that from various sources as
well as my own and perhaps most of all a
piece that I wrote last fall as on the
seventh seventh birthday really at the
site well which was about seven things
that I learned in those seven years of
reading writing and living which is a
great article and I didn't want to
replicate everything in here so I sort
of bobbed and weaved around some of
these subjects a little bit but just to
reiterate something that you mentioned
and that's doing nothing for prestige er
status or money or approval alone and
it's what I quote Paul Graham here which
you included it which is prestigious
like a powerful manga that warps even
your beliefs about what you enjoy it
causes you to work not on what you like
but what you would like to like which i
think is so stupid
and enclosing is there and also I should
just interject and say any Alan Watts
piece not because my writing about it is
so great or it's not coming from a place
of check me out it's coming from a place
of check him out Alan Watts has changed
my life I've written about him quite a
bit so I highly recommend any of those
articles cool all right brain picking
zorg is the site guys check it out maria
any parting advice for this episode this
portion of our conversation but before
we before we check out any advice to the
people listening out there thoughts
parting comments no advice per se just I
guess a comment and a hope which is that
that you know thank you so much not just
for having me but for having this show
and
doing everything that you do and I
really hope we have more people who
operate out of such a place of just I
guess for lack of better word idealism
and conviction and yeah thank you for
setting an example that way well that
means a lot coming from you and I think
I think you're a tremendous force for
good out there in the world so I hope
people check out your work I hope you
continue to do what you're doing I hope
you continue to add repetitions to your
pull-ups and we will we will talk again
soon thank thank you so much for being
on the show thank you for supporting the
sponsors of this show 99designs
which is your one-stop shop for all
things graphic design related go to
99designs comm forward slash tim to see
the projects that I've put up including
the mock-ups and drafts of the book
cover for the 4-hour body ex-officio
ex-officio and I go way back
ex-officio dot-com forward slash Tim you
can see the clothing that I've used for
traveling through 20 plus countries
including the underwear by the way
that's about half of my underwear drawer
right now ex officio com forward slash
Tim you can also see the viral video
that I put out which shows you how to
travel the world with 10 pounds or less
as always you can subscribe to this
podcast on iTunes and you can find all
of the links and resources from this
episode as well as every other episode
by going to 4-hour workweek comm forward
slash podcast spell it all out or you
can go to 4-hour work week calm and just
click on podcast feedback if you have
feedback I would love your thoughts
anything at all
who you'd like to see on this show ping
me on Twitter that's T Faris that's
Twitter com /t fer Riss or on facebook
at facebook.com forward slash Tim
Ferriss with two R's and two S's and
until next time thank you for listening